- My mom worked nine to six at the bank
and my dad worked three
to 12 at the shipyard.
It was all for us kids,
they just worked so hard to make us happy.
Ay.
- Ay.
That's what I want for my
daughters, just to be happy.
Alright, they don't have any
toddler-sized Moana costumes
so I'm gonna try and make one
of my own for my daughter.
(Wife and daughter laugh)
She's big into Moana.
The other night she even
woke up asking for Moana.
I've got an old shirt, some
fabric that I bought off of eBay
and I got some Velcro just in case.
But this is just a kids costume,
she won't even remember it.
My wife Kate doesn't think I can do it,
I'm gonna prove her wrong.
(upbeat music)
Flynn is sleeping, so obviously
I can't put these clothes
on her, that'd be weird
and would wake her up and she'd be grumpy.
So I'm gonna use my teddy bear Gumdy
who I've had since I was five.
He's roughly the size of Flynn.
It'll just give me an idea
of how it'll look on her.
Gumdy won't be embarrassed, I'm sure.
So Moana's dress is
strapless but that's probably
not gonna work for a toddler,
so I'm just gonna use
this drawstring that I pulled
from an old BuzzFeed hoodie.
Kate doesn't think this is gonna work,
I think it's coming together.
Who's that?
What are you doing?
You hit your head.
You okay?
- Moana.
- You're wearing a Moana outfit.
- It's Sunday, I went to
the fabric store and got
more things to make the
costume look a little better.
I got some ribbon for the top,
I got some new fabric for the skirt,
and I got some buttons to make
putting on the top easier.
Making this Halloween
costume for my daughter
makes me remember how my
parents made Halloween costumes
for me when I was a kid.
I remember when I was
eight, my mom helped me
make a Dick Tracy costume.
We made the hat out of posterboard.
When I was 15 my dad made me Jedi robes.
My mom worked nine to six at the bank
and my dad worked three to
12 midnight at the shipyard.
For them to take out that
time means so much more now
than I understand.
They did their best.
They did their best to make me happy.
It was all for us kids,
there were five of us.
They just worked so hard to make us happy.
That's what I want for my daughter,
I just hope it makes her happy.
- [Jared] Say hi, can you see me?
Say hi Lola.
Doing the things for my
daughter that they did for me
makes me realize how
much my parents loved me.
And like I knew they loved
me, but I didn't understand
how deep that love was.
- [Jared] Say bye bye!
- Bye bye.
- [Man] Love you mom!
- Love you.
- You like Moana?
(laughs) what kind of smile was that?
I think I did pretty good, huh?
- [Wife] Mhm, A plus.
- A plus?
An A plus, very good.
(upbeat music)